la licence le petit dernier de la
famille quesada va tomber dans la
marginalité il séchait les cours il
était irrévérencieuse et professeurs
fassent était devenu de pire et elles
sont de son lycée et alors qu'il est âgé
de 21 ans 1 g familiale va traumatiser
le jeune christian il a été assez marqué
par le suicide de son d'un de ses frères
aînés qui s'est défenestré et christian
quesada a découvert le corps cet
événement tragique va finalement faire
prendre conscience à christian que lui
aussi était un peu sur une pente
glissante
on a cinq quintaux de cuivre sur
christian quesada guillaume c'est un
truc de fou vous avez des nouvelles voix
lors la première info c'est en dehors du
procès verbal et beaucoup de gens qui se
demandent où est christian quesada il a
été aperçu il ya quelques semaines
ammann be any way à villefranche sur mer
dans le sud de la france à villefranche
sur mer dans le sud de la france il
était seul dans une petite rue étroite
pas loin d'une école une ruche ouais une
rue étroite et il avait l'habitude de se
rendre dans le sud de la france
christian quesada puisque le 27 février
2019 lorsque la police a essayé de
l'arrêter une première fois il n'était
pas chez lui il avait été aperçu
localisé sur la croisette à cannes ou à
l'été dans le sud de la france aperçu à
quelques semaines d'accord première
information deuxième information donc le
procès verbal de christian quesada le
jugement qu'elle était sa motivation à
parler à des mineurs garçon et fille sur
internet voilà ce qu'il répond je
voulais fantasmer avoir des
conversations sexuel le plus possible
pourquoi avec des mineurs parce que les
réseaux sociaux sont plus fréquentées
par les mineurs j'ai un problème avec la
tranche d'âge 15 21 ans je suis plus à
l'aise à parler avec des mineurs qu'avec
des gens de mon âge ça premier élément
du procès verbal un des arguments de
défense de quesada aussi c'est qu'il
n'est jamais passé à l'acte or on se
rend compte en france et verbales que
c'est faux en fait il avait donné rendez
vous à une jeune fille à travers une
fausse identité vous savez qu'il avait
des faux comptes où il se faisait passer
pour de jeunes d'adolescente et
l'adolescente avait dit à une jeune
mineure est-ce que ça t'intéresserait de
coucher avec un homme de 50 ans pour 200
euros un homme qui a gagné aux 12 coups
de midi donc récent quesada la jeune
fille accepte christian quesada fixe un
rendez vous donne un lieu de rendez-vous
un hôtel près de la gare de lyon la
fille refuse finalement de se rendre au
rendez vous sauf que problème christian
quesada lui s'est rendu sur le lieu du
rendez vous à deux reprises à l'hôtel
donc le juge lui dit mais vous vouliez
passer à l'acte et finit par reconnaître
que oui il s'est rendu sur le lieu du
rendez-vous à deux reprises donc ils
avaient l'intention de passer à l'acte
même si ça n'a pas lieu on a deux autres
infos on est juste revoir dans le
documentaire on découvre aussi cette
histoire folle qui date de 2001 une
plainte avait été déposée à l'encontre
de christian quesada il avait montré un
magazine pornographique un enfant de 11
ans dans un parc regardez sa défense
pour cette plainte est complètement
folle regarder le show qu'on regarde
un après midi il est dans un parc
d'anthony
il croise un petit garçon de 11 ans
à qui il va montrer une revue porno
l'enfant un petit peu interloqué
retourne voir son père en lui disant qu
un monsieur s'est dirigé vers lui un
monsieur qui ne connaît pas avec un
magazine assez étonnant et le papa
retombe dans le parc et christian
quesada est toujours là avec ce fameux
magazine de femme nue sous le bras et
c'est à ce moment là qu'une première
plainte sera déposée
aussi fou que cela puisse paraître aux
policiers qui vont l'interroger
christian quesada explique s'être tout
simplement tromper d'interlocuteur
il va justifier le fait de se promener
avec un magazine porno en disant qu'il
allait le vendre à un collectionneur et
que bon il a imaginé que c'était ce
petit garçon
j -louis ce qui est fou c'est le trou il
ya 2001 2003 où il a à des plaintes
contre lui il est condamné à du sursis
il ya eu un manque de suivi de la
justice qui est reconnu aujourd'hui
c'est hallucinant la justice reconnaît
jamais aujourd'hui elle procureur qui
dit oui il a eu un trou il aurait dû
être inscrits vraiment au fichier des
délinquants sexuels pour ne pas
récidiver donc c'est le manque de
condamnations lourdes et de suivi à
l'époque qui a occasionné tout ce qui
est arrivé après c'est pas lui c'est
incroyable cette affaire est unique il
n'aurait jamais dû pouvoir être une star
des jeux télé on l'apprend aujourd'hui
alors on apprend aussi la raison son
divorce facile j'avais des infos non
mais c'est facile de dire ça après coup
on a on a tout ça on a tous suivi pour
le coup on a tous ceux et celles après
couvertures
ont fait pas des 100 kg
on avait sorti son 15eme diarrhée deux
ans il y avait cinq saisons comme le
bras et tout le monde le savait alors je
suis désolé on l'a ou la produire du
monde le savait quand on a le quasi
détecté
il a dit
c'est pas la tête il ya deux ans oui je
dormais comme d'habitude au repas
isabelle sur elle végète
on apprend aussi la région son divorce
qu'il se déroule en 2009 sa femme aurait
surpris des conversations avec mes jeune
fille ainsi que des photos pédo
pornographiques sur son ordinateur alors
qu'il rentrait de lune de miel rendez
compte pas direct wallonia c'est parti
sur quesada a raconté dans son livre son
divorce avec la mère de ses enfants mon
couple n'a pas tenu
la différence d'âge peut-être les
horaires de boulot décalés ou simplement
l'amour fans et trop vite juste après
leur lune de miel sa femme l'aurait
surpris de retour de voyage de noces
elle va découvrir que son époux a des
contacts sur internet avec de très
jeunes adolescents
sa femme va le démasquer en tombant sur
des photos
à caractère pédopornographique dans
l'ordinateur de famille et elle va
réaliser que christian quesada son
compagnon se faisant passer pour des
jeunes filles pour récolter des images
dénudées valérie bénaïm une info plaît
c'est son épouse qui va aller voir la
police et qui va le dénoncer c'est son
épouse qui est tellement choquée par ce
qu'elle vient de découvrir qui va
ensuite est vraiment de dire que sur son
mari est un potentiel pédopornographes
mais elle va pas qu'est ce qu'il fout
seigneur va porter plainte d'ailleurs je
viens de dire faut vraiment karas une
réunion où c'est l'accumulation des
preuves star qu'il avait pas quelques
photos pornographiques il avait des
milliers de photos pédopornographiques
sur ses ordinateurs depuis des années il
en recevait il en prenait lui-même avec
ses appareils photos il n'en ait changé
aussi avec d'autres personnes qui
avaient des comportements pédophiles
donc on peut dire qu'il faisait partie
d'un réseau et ses addictions il les
reconnaissait alors c'est quoi ces
addictions alors donc le procès verbal
je rappelle l'inca la conversation entre
le juge et christian quesada lors de son
art et ils se les procurer en
exclusivité entraînons hoffman a été
transcrit et il reconnaît lui même ses
addictions donc le juge lui demande avez
vous des problèmes de dépendance au jeu
aux stupéfiants à l'alcool et au sexe
quesada répond un peu à tout vous me
demandez quelle drogue un peu tous et
une consommation irrégulière qui peut
être excessive l'alcoolisme c'est de
l'alcoolisme solitaire le sexe oui je
suis dépendant donc il a tout de suite
tout reconnu en fait tous ses vices et
c'est quelqu'un qui était extrêmement
torture visiblement alors on a on a
encore une autre info un secret sur
quesada encore et qu'ils font chier
parce que c'est ce qu'il y en a une au
delà la réponse dans un instant
guillaume juste avant regardé au monde
son procès aussi on découvre que le coc
vide a eu de lourdes conséquences sur la
manière dont il est donc non ci s'est
déroulée absent de victimes de leurs
avocats christian quesada décide même de
révoquer son avocat la dernière minute
regarde
face à ses juges christian quesada prend
la parole l'homme continue de minimiser
cet or est à l'entendre ces déviances
sexuelles auraient pour origine un
soucis de santé quand il était
adolescent il avait un prêt au pénis qui
selon lui a handicapé sa vie sexuelle
c'est sur l'une des explications de ses
attirances pour les enfants et les
adolescents les justifications de
l'accusé ne pèse pas lourd face aux
accusations de corruption de mineurs de
détention et diffusion d'imagés
pédopornographiques
j'ai la grande question c'est
effectivement il y avait une
sous-représentation des victimes au
procès d'abord y avait le vide et
ensuite il faut bien le dire
beaucoup de victimes jeunes et leurs
familles n'ont pas souhaité porter
plainte la question c'est aurait-il pu
être condamné plus lourdement s'il y
avait eu ses victimes il a pris trois
ans de prison il ne l'a pas fait mais il
a pris trois ans hélas pour certaines
personnes qui pensent qu'il aurait pu
être condamné plus lourdement la
condamnation à trois ans elle est quand
même symbole d'une lourde peine donc on
peut pas dire que le projet était vicié
truqué il a été lourdement condamné
franchement il a fait qu'un haut rhin
oui et puis parfois son avocat l'a
lâchée lors de ce procès parce que le
dossier était quasiment indéfendable et
la ligne de défense de glissade à
extrêmement fout un coup il reconnaît
les faits un coup il reconnaît pas a
prédit qu'il voit pas vraiment le
problème avec le fait d'entretenir des
conversations à caractères sexuels avec
des mineurs donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile à défendre là il
parlait de 2,2 problèmes de santé ça n'a
ni queue ni tête donc c'était
extrêmement dur pour lui de trouver un
avocat qu'il est défendu convenablement
alors vous me dites pas ce qui est des
rumeurs compris serait fâché vous avez
vous dire ce qu'il en est l'un des
autres moments forts de ce documentaire
ces témoignages des parents d'une
victime qui avait 13 ans à l'époque elle
avait été victime du procédé bien rodée
de christian quesada qui avait utilisé
une nouvelle fois un faux profil
regarder
à la gendarmerie le père et la mère de
la petite juliette
découvre ce que tous les parents
redoutent là j'ai vu les poteaux de ma
fille un déni des comptes avec des
parties précises en plus j'ai halluciné
je ne sais pas possible de demander des
photos pareil c'est des photos très
gênante pour une maman
les photos c'était dur à voir
je suis
malheureux jamais soupçonné ce qui
c'était ce qui s'était passé a peut être
lui a demandé qui c'était passé par la
tête pour envoyer des photos comme ça
l'image est fait par dépit parce que
c'était des échanges l'assistant donc à
la fin vers cd en visant à envoyer
quelques photos
en fait chris encaissa il avait deux
techniques pour a fait voler le
testicule merci
pour approcher ses victimes présumées
soit scellé victime qui venait à lui
puisque il jouissait d'une grande
notoriété dont il y avait des jeunes
femmes parfois mineures qui le contacter
et il en profitait pour enclencher une
conversation soit il se faisait passer
pour de jeunes adolescentes vente en
racontant une certaine justine est il
rentré en contact avec des jeunes filles
de 14 ans 15 ans il commençait par une
discussion normale entre deux jeunes
filles en disant voilà bah je suis
complexé par mon corps regarde d'être
montré mes seins je t'envoie une photo
de mes cendres dit prenez une fausse
photo pour recevoir en échange des
photos de ces jeunes femmes alors il ya
un extrait qui était fou c'est le
témoignage du procureur de la république
en charge de la faire il partage son
ressenti ça ce jugement de christian
quesada et parle d'un échec de la
justice regardez
christophe rodde le procureur de la
république de bourg-en-bresse en charge
de la sphère de 2017 le reconnaît
christian quesada n'auraient pas dû
passer entre les mailles du filet de la
justice
il faisait partie des gens qui étaient
catalogués comme étant des délinquants
sexuels lorsque l'on constate que à
nouveau il est passé à l'acte et
vis-à-vis de plusieurs autres
adolescentes peut qu'en déduire que
quelque part oui sans doute qu'il ya un
peu un échec
et il ya un autre problème souvenez vous
la faire démarrer en mai 2017 avec la
plainte de la jeune clarisse or
christian quesada est arrêté seulement
deux ans après en mars 2019
mais ces problématiques effectivement le
ca a mis énormément de temps et le
prennent c'est qu'il ya une dualité chez
christian quesada d'un côté c'est un
dangereux prédateur mais de l'autre côté
c'est un homme bien sous tous rapports
quand on le voyait sur les 12 coups de
midi il était extrêmement sympathique
les gens l'aimaient beaucoup et c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un se comporte bien
dans certaines situations ou qu'il a une
vie amoureuse d'ailleurs normal c'est
qu'à côté de ça il avait aussi des
relations consenties avec des femmes
adultes mais c'est pas pour ça que par
ailleurs il peut avoir des comportements
extrêmement déplacé donc c'est toute la
dualité chez christian quesada qui est
très difficile à cerner alors venez nous
dire ce qu'il en est de tous les sous
qu'il a gagné mais juste allait ruiner
vous vouliez dire qu'ils voulaient
j'espère que là on voit qu'il ya un vrai
dysfonctionnements parce que il ya une
plainte en 2010 et en 2010 est qui qui
touche une mineure et on ne s'intéresse
vrai véritablement ce sujet qu'en 2019
donc quand ça touche les mineurs c'est
là où il ne devrait pas y avoir de
défaillance ne devrait pas y avoir de
retard dans la justice puisque à passer
là pour le coup c'est extrême ce devrait
diligenter immédiatement ça devrait être
extrêmement rapide et c'est là où il ya
une vraie faille dans ce dossier
guillaume lautour oui gilles enquête a
été complexe aussi parce que c'était
entre paris et lun c'est à dire que ça a
été compliqué il y avait pardon oui bon
cambrai oui merci oui dans la et il y
avait des images il y avait plein
d'image qui ont été difficiles à
décrypter il y avait effectivement des
familles qui n'ont pas souhaité
s'associer au dossier ça a été plus
complexe que ça à mon avis le problème
il est quand même plus avant que pendant
les deux ans de l'enquète oui
bourg-en-bresse et dans la mer si elle a
le droit par le
problème c'est qu'au début on dit c'est
pensé que c'était ainsi à isoler et
quand ils ont commencé à faire des
perquisitions chez lui à se rendre
compte qu'ils avaient des milliers de
fichiers qui parlait avec des centaines
et des centaines de jeunes femmes qui
prenaient des photos à leur insu de
jeune fille sous leur jupe quand il
était dans des supermarchés tout ça
c'est vraiment immonde et c'est plus
qu'une simple histoire avec une jeune
fille a énormément de caractéristiques
dans cette affaire qui sont extrêmement
graves il ya delà de la pédophilie de la
prostitution et donc c'est une affaire
extrêmement lourdes et c'est ça aussi
qui fait enquête alors qu'est ce qu'il
en est il de tout l'argent qu'il a gagné
lafreux alors est ce maintenant parce
qu'on hammami qui est en train de les
quitter
ça va les y profiter vous pour vous m
non monsieur équipe qui veut des
caramels
un petit caramel mou et sa main du zen
c'est tout procès tout frais mais
revault sur ses finances parce qu'il a
gagné beaucoup d'argent en douze coups
de midi et là forcément ça fait
plusieurs années qu'ils ne touchent plus
d'argent c'est quelqu'un qui vit avec le
rsa encore avant le jeu et dans le
procès verbal dont il parle de ses
finances ouvertement et que le juge il
dit j'ai gagné six cent mille euros 12
coups de midi il nous reste soixante dix
mille euros sur mon compte j'ai offert
trois cent mille euros à mes enfants
acheter un studio à 30000 euros à
béziers prêter 80 mille euros à mon
frère le reste je les dépenses et en
voyage donc il ne reste entre guillemets
que soixante dix mille euros à question
quesada il a dépensé cinq cent trente
mille euros sur les 600 mines qui les
gravissent et refaire les dents aussi
15000 euros d'accord merci c'est
important mais c'est important
bernard est bonne est bonne info une
info dentaire ça marche la grande
question qui se pose maintenant c'est
effectivement on l'a vu guillaume le
disais dans le sud selon nos
informations il aurait donné un domicile
autour de perpignan il avait quitté son
village dans l'ain son sens le
documentaire la loi en bresse brabant à
côté à hauteville mais c'est près de
bourg-en-bresse dans l'ain et c'est vrai
qu' il serait prêt permanent il est
obligé de donner une adresse et surtout
il a une obligation de cinq ans de soins
ça c'est très important parce que pour
le moment à chaque fois qu'il a été
condamné à chaque fois qu'ils devaient
faire des soins il ne les a pas suivis
là selon nos informations ils les
suivent il faut savoir que le moindre
manquement il retourne immédiatement en
prison